it's difficult to believe that this is
California a state in the grip of
several years of drought but the rains
have arrived with a Vengeance Rivers and
Creeks bursting their Banks trapping
people in their homes and cars the
previously bone dry land cannot cope the
onslaught of water sending mud and rock
Boulders tumbling towards Mountainside
towns
Ray is surveying the damage but didn't
bargain for the cement-like mud you've
got huge Rock mountains everywhere
water just piles up and when it does
this is where it comes given the fact
that we've destroyed and polluted our
our environment beyond all belief
but
human race does what it wants and
Mother Nature will do what she does
whether we like it or not
they're more used to wildfires than
floods around here but some places are
experiencing their wettest 10 days for
more than a century at least 16 people
have died so far a five-year-old boy was
swept away after his mother's car was
trapped in flood water he is still
missing
the entire town of Montecito home to the
super wealthy including Prince Harry and
Megan has been evacuated but not before
one of its most famous residents issued
a warning
[Music]
about nine feet up mother nature his
mother nature
roads across California are blocked this
is sort of impassable at the moment
isn't it it is yeah so last night my
wife and myself we couldn't get home
Jason is trying to get through to rescue
a neighbor who's been bitten by a dog
and needs medical treatment they're not
gonna be able to make it across so she's
wondering if she could just have one of
the other vehicles drive him across and
then shoot my dad might take him to the
hospital
some are seeing the bright side but with
more extreme weather on the way
the worst May yet be to come